there's one L there's one more step in
in post-production because you know it's
the end that the film editor you know
he's going to cut and paste and trim put
everything together to make it look like
a movie now there are many things he or
she can do to achieve that effect now he
can use just a few shots to show you how
a man sizes up his adversary he can cut
with that like speed to cover all of the
angles of a complicated action sequence
he can artfully incorporate historical
footage with carefully matched new
footage to let the audience travel back
in time he can use a bollywood rhythm to
create incredible tension excitement and
suspense and he can select a few choice
shots that give the audience the movie
moment that they've been waiting for the
nominees for film editing are Mike Hill
and Dan Handley for frost/nixon
Lee Smith for the Dark Knight Elliott
Graham from milk Chris Dickens for
Slumdog Millionaire
Kirk Baxter and angus wall for the
Curious Case of Benjamin Button and the
Oscar goes to Slumdog Millionaire Oh
Chris Dickens
you
you
thank you so much for this thank you
everyone who voted for me this is
incredible I just want to say I had a
fantastic time working on this film it
was I really didn't want it to end I had
a wonderful time in India and so I'd
like to thank my crew in India firstly
that was Vivek you Diane and I read her
they were fantastic and also in England
Tina and Tom we worked really hard in
the editing with us to get the film
finished and also my family my sisters
Sally Ali Lizzy my parents my wife Cleo
who sort of put up with all the hours I
was working disappearing and but
especially to Danny who's over there
Danny and Christian and and Simon and
Anthony for just producing such great
material you know fantastic stuff to
work with so I am thank you and yeah
you've really inspired me so I'm really
proud thank you
more with host Hugh Jackman and a
tribute to Jerry Lewis when we return